[Musica]
ciao eccoci qui ragazzi oggi vi voglio
raccontare la storia di uno dei più
grandi furti di sempre di qualcosa che
ci stanno togliendo anche in questo
esatto momento ma di cui nella maggior
parte dei casi non ne siamo consapevoli
non solo vedremo anche come possiamo
riprenderci quello che ora ci stanno
togliendo infatti questa non è solo la
storia di un furto questa è la storia di
una rivoluzione è una rivoluzione che
riguarda alla fine tutti noi
ma partiamo dall'inizio
non so se vi è in braille che avvitata
vi siete accorti quando parli di un
prodotto parli di un servizio parliamo
qualcosa e subito dopo ti ritrovi
stalker izzato da quel prodotto e dalle
sue pubblicità questa cosa qui per chi
si occupa di marketing lo sa si chiama
profilazione e permette a tutte quelle
persone brutte e capire che fanno
pubblicità di scegliere esattamente le
persone a cui mostrare il proprio
messaggio
le aziende che fanno la profilazione che
ci profilano sono così bravi nel farlo
perché ci conoscono benissimo sanno
tutto quello che ci piace
tutto quello che vediamo sanno le
persone con cui parliamo sono quelle
persone a cui pensiamo che sono quelle
che seguiamo sui social
conoscono tutte le nostre abitudini
nostre preferenze i nostri acquisti i
nostri posti preferiti i nostri orari e
ascoltano anche i nostri discorsi
l'università di stanford ha dimostrato
una cosa molto inquietante che con 150
like l'algoritmo di facebook può
conoscerci meglio di un nostro familiare
o di un nostro amico
allora la domanda è come è possibile è
possibile grazie all'ingrediente segreto
di questa nostra nuova economia che è un
bene molto prezioso che tutti noi
produciamo costantemente sempre anche in
questo momento e che ci viene rubato
legalmente
sto parlando dei nostri dati qualsiasi
cosa ne facciamo
lasciamo una scia dei nostri dati non ce
ne rendiamo conto siamo tutti i giorni
ap dispositivi che tracciano o tutto ciò
che facciamo tutti i nostri dati anche
quando non utilizziamo il telefono
questo per esempio è il tracciamento di
google la timeline di google in cui sono
tracciati tutti i nostri spostamenti poi
possiamo andare su un giorno specifico e
vedere tutti gli spostamenti che abbiamo
fatto in quel giorno stessa cosa fa
facebook e stessa cosa fanno tanti altri
dispositivi questo per esempio il fit
bit che traccia non solo la nostra
localizzazione ma anche i nostri dati
biometrici e a proposito di questo ho
trovato uno stress su internet molto
divertente di come per la prima volta
sono stati utilizzati i dati di un
feedback in un processo è la storia di
quest'uomo che era spesso fuori città
per lavoro e aveva dei dubbi sulla
fedeltà della moglie
così dal tablet in comune quindi senza
commettere illeciti perché poi stata
utilizzata questa prova in tribunale
quando lei ha iniziato a guardare gli
spostamenti dal fit bit sia accorto che
quando noi era fuori città lei alle 2 di
notte usciva andava sempre nello stesso
posto altra caratteristica che dobbiamo
dire è che il battito cardiaco
accellerava per 30 minuti quindi a
questo punto da una parte o mio dio lo
molto inquietante questa cosa qui
possiamo veramente ricostruire la nostra
vita dalla a alla z dall'altra
qualcun'altro starà pensando wow lo 30
minuti non è male ma scherzi a parte
come vengono utilizzati i nostri dati lo
abbiamo detto prima per quanto riguarda
la pubblicità per sapere esattamente a
chi mostrare qualcosa le personalità
delle persone che sono quelle persone le
ma dall'altra parte
questa bisogna vedere questa slide
perché è molto interessante anche
vengono utilizzati i dati anche per
creare messaggi più persuasivi questo
signore qui è il suo di cambridge
analitica che una società di marketing e
in questa conferenza specifica spiega la
strategia data driven quindi basata sui
dati che hanno utilizzato per creare i
messaggi di marketing che hanno poi
contribuito a far vincere donald trump
alle elezioni a presidente degli stati
uniti ovviamente in questa conferenza ha
sorvolato sul fatto che erano trafugato
da facebook e da di 87 milioni di
persone e quindi con questi dati
sicuramente sono stati agevolati per
creare dei messaggi pubblicitari
specifici che hanno suonato e dovrebbe
essere online si trova tutta la
conferenza in cui racconta il loro
metodo il modello
questo questa storia è stata poi
raccontata diciamo da dietro le quinte
dal documentario the way back che ha
messo in luce l'aspetto oscuro legato ai
dati perché di fatto sono i nostri dati
ma noi come proprietari di questi dati
come utenti non ne sappiamo niente non
sappiamo chi sa che dati a come li usa a
chi vende a quanto li vende non sappiamo
niente ne abbiamo il minimo controllo su
questi dati allora
non so se avete mai sentito questa frase
quando non capisci qual è il prodotto il
prodotto sei tu e lo specifico il
prodotto solo i nostri dati in un certo
senso quello che sta succedendo con
internet oggi da una parte perché
dall'altro mondo meraviglioso però in
questo senso sembra quello che succede
negli allevamenti intensivi no come
utenti siamo noi le mucche del digitale
da cui viene estratto il prodotto lo
racconta anche un altro documentario che
siano adesso cialda elem che
probabilmente avete visto forse in modo
un po troppo grammatico però di fatto
queste aziende cosa fanno nutrono la
nostra attenzione per trattenersi più
tempo possibile sulle loro piattaforme
ci sono degli psicologi che fanno questo
cercano modi per trattenerci più tempo
possibile nel frattempo ci mungono i
dati che poi utilizzano per mostrarci
pubblicità profilata oppure che vendono
ma c'è una piccola differenza che i dati
valgono un po più del latte molto più
del latte i dati valgono oro infatti si
dice che i dati sono il nuovo oro e sono
alla base di tutta l'economia digitale
tecnologica pensate che l'intelligenza
artificiale e nutrita con i dati
l'industria dei dati è un'industria
sconfinata che sta aumentando di anno in
anno in modo esponenziale oggi vale
mille oltre mille miliardi di dollari
vuol dire che ogni minuto vengono
comprati venduti utilizzati dati per un
milione di dollari ogni minuto
allora la domanda che mi viene
automatiche ma chi guadagna da tutti
questi dati a guadagnarci sono queste
aziende che si chiamano data broker si
sarebbero i mercanti dei dati che li
compra vengono ma soprattutto i data già
ians
i giganti dei dati i data giants sono le
grandi aziende tech che compra vengono
dati o li usano come asset come un
valore per fare poi profitto su altro
come nella pubblicità per esempio i dati
però sono la materia prima sono la
materia prima con cui queste aziende
fanno i fatturati più alti nella storia
dell'umanità tra l'altro con questi
fatturati faranno anche di profitti
incredibile parliamo dal 70 al 90 per
cento in su di profitto come è possibile
se c'è un piccolo negoziante che fa
fatica a stare in piedi e questi fanno
il 90 per cento del profitto facendo i
fatturati più alti al mondo
perché a differenza del piccolo
negoziante di tante altre aziende che si
fanno il mazzo per riuscire a rimanere a
galla questi signori non pagano la
materia prima non pagano i nostri dati e
noi come utenti infatti non riceviamo
neanche un centesimo da tutto questo
giro d'affari e questo è uno dei più
grandi furti legalizzati della storia ma
allora ci siamo siamo siamo tutti matti
siamo tutti scemi come è possibile che
non ci rendiamo conto del valore dei
dati e li diamo in cambio di noccioline
senza neanche pensarci magari non hanno
tutto questo valore e invece no
e purtroppo non è neanche colpa nostra
perché l'economia dei dati si è
sviluppata così velocemente solo
recentemente che non abbiamo neanche
fatto in tempo a capire cosa sta
succedendo e non è neanche la prima
volta che una cosa del genere accade ora
vi racconto una similitudine che mi è
venuta in mente quando i conquistadores
per la prima volta arrivarono nelle
americhe indigeni non davano lo stesso
valore che l'europa dava loro ma lo
utilizzavano solamente per fini estetici
quindi avevano dei monili o delle
statuine d'oro e così conquistador s
riuscirono a portare via valanghe e
valanghe di oro ai nativi in cambio di
pelli e altri oggetti di poco valore
perché i nativi non avevano idea che
c'era un mercato dell'oro è che questo
metallo valesse così tanto ma non
avevano neanche dall'altra parte accesso
a questo mercato ma con quel materiale
giallo a cui loro davano poca importanza
qualcun altro ci stava facendo una
fortuna e mi sembra mi sembra di con mi
sembra che la stessa cosa sta succedendo
oggi con i nostri dati questi signori
riprendono li usano li vendono ci fanno
una fortuna e noi in cambio riceviamo
briciole ma se questo è un tema così
importante
cosa sta successo cosa sta succedendo
nel mondo ci saranno delle risposte
il punto è che questa è quella sui dati
a una vera e propria guerra e da una
parte ci sono i regolatori chi fa le
leggi e non so se vi ricordate tutta
l'indagine che c'è stata a seguito dello
scandalo di cambridge analitica che
questa qui che vediamo nella slide i
regolatori da qualche anno soprattutto
in europa stanno intervenendo con regole
sempre più specifiche per tutelare e
proteggere i dati degli utenti ad
esempio agili pr è un regolamento
europeo
all'avanguardia in ambito di data
protection and privacy ma a queste tutte
queste nuove regole come reagiscono poi
i giganti dei dati sono stati fermati
finalmente hanno riconosciuto il valore
di dati proprio te no niente tutto
questo semplicemente cosa fanno
allungano i termini e condizioni e
presente quando per registrarti è un
servizio di cliccare su accetta e
termine condizioni vengono chiamati tos
tornassero ad essa in quel momento noi
firmiamo il patto col diavolo né l'unica
cosa che possiamo fare per utilizzare
quel servizio se tu hai mai letto i
termini e condizioni è quasi impossibile
per un motivo perché sono lunghissime
pensate che i termini e condizioni di
paypal sono più lunghi della mileto di
shakespeare mentre quelli di itunes sono
più lunghi del macbeth di shakespeare ma
il problema è che non sono solo lunghi
sono anche complicatissimi pensate che
sette avvocati si sono messi a studiare
per sette giorni i termini e condizioni
di itunes e non sono riusciti alla fine
a dire con esattezza ciò che lo stava
accertando e non accettando con quei
termini e condizioni
poi se da una parte ci sono i regolatori
e questo è quello che succede a seguito
delle delle regole non tutto però
diciamo questo rappresenta bene una
reazione del mercato dall'altra parte ci
sono aziende che si scontrano per
prendere i dati degli utenti e altre
aziende che hanno iniziato a schierarsi
invece dalla parte della privacy
introducendo protezioni per l'utente
questa per esempio apple che è stata una
delle prime che qualche anno fa
introdotto queste cose qui che benvenuti
mate nutrition lei ball sono delle
etichette di nutrimento come avviene per
i cibi spiegano in modo visivo quali
dati queste app stanno prendendo vi
faccio vedere questa tabella di
comparazione che un po piccola ma ve la
spiego e la comparazione tra le tabelle
di nutrimento a confronto delle app di
messaggistica quindi quella più grande
che vedete quanto di qua e facebook
messenger che prende di facebook
ovviamente prende tutto quello che si
può prenderlo l'ansa niente poi c'è
whatsapp sempre facebook che prende una
bella valanga di dati pò cioè imessage
che è di apple che prende pochissimi
dati e poi si narra che un app che
quella anche consigliata da must qualche
tempo fa che prende 0 dati è sempre
apple ha introdotto con ios 14 a questa
funzione che si chiama asc ap not track
che è un ulteriore rinforzamento della
privacy che permette agli utenti di
scegliere di non essere tracciati da
un'app perché non tutti lo sanno ma le
app non tracciano solo quello che tu fai
quando sei sulla traccia mo pure tutto
il resto quindi la tua cronologia i tuoi
acquisti i tuoi spostamenti
le foto che sul telefono tutto e pensate
che con l'introduzione di questa
funzione solamente il 5 per cento degli
utenti ha detto ok ha dato il consenso
essere tracciato vuol dire che il 95 per
cento degli utenti non voleva essere
tracciato ma non aveva alternative
quindi abbiamo detto ci sono queste due
grandi forze da una parte il mondo sta
andando verso il tracciare tutto il
tracciabile anche quando dispositivi io
voglio sapere esattamente sempre
l'ossigeno mio sangue scusa del
commercio hanno cose voglio sapere tutto
ma dall'altra parte c'è un movimento che
va verso la protezione della privacy per
non far perdere a far prendere queste
aziende tutti i nostri dati e quindi c'è
da fare però una considerazione perché
come osserva il wall kevin kelly che il
co fondatore di wired un'esperienza no
data quindi con un massima privacy in
quell azienda non ha nessuno dei nostri
dati è un'esperienza generica mentre un
esperienza con i dati è un'esperienza
personalizzata e alla fine io
personalmente preferisco vedere una
pubblicità sulle cripto valute piuttosto
che una sugli assorbenti preferisco apre
in youtube e vedere dei video che mi
interessano di persone che stimo o gli
argomenti che non mi fanno schifo
diciamo come preferisco aprire spotify
trovare le mie playlist preferisco
trovare magari sentire
della musica che può essere più affine
ai miei gusti piuttosto che ascoltare
musica generica o vedere musica gennario
e magari più avanti quando la medicina
lo permetterà preferirei un farmaco
tarato esattamente sulla mia salute sui
miei dati della salute il mio standard
di salute che sono diversi nei dati
medici dai tuoi da quelli di tutte le
altre persone quindi forse la soluzione
non è in uno di questi poli quindi non è
dare tutti i dati senza avere controllo
nel trasparenza e non avere niente
indietro nè dall'altra non dare più
imitati a nessuno che sembra la
controtendenza che sta arrivando
forse se riconoscessimo i dati come un
asset un valore di nostra proprietà con
tutto quello che ne consegue quelli
avere trasparenza e controllo su questi
dati ma soprattutto ricevere magari una
rendita economica dato che i soldi li
producono
potrebbe essere la soluzione è come dire
la soluzione non è in immaginando i dati
come se fossero delle canzoni la
soluzione non ascoltiamo più le canzoni
ma che quando una canzone viene
riprodotto acquistata come avviene gli
artisti che ne detengono i diritti
guadagnano una royalty su una
commissione non potrebbe accadere la
stessa cosa con i nostri dati ovvero che
quando vengono utilizzati comprati
venduti in noi guadagniamo una
commissione
questi questa cosa qui che sembra una
stupidaggine cosa piccola in realtà
potrebbe creare il primo reddito
generato dai nostri dati personali
un reddito che arriva al di là del
nostro lavoro
ok gigi sembra una roba interessante ma
quanto potrebbero generare i nostri dati
questa è una domanda che mi sono chiesto
anche io per primo allora per rispondere
vi racconto come il mio fratello siamo
incappati abbiamo scoperto questo mondo
dei dati noi da quasi dieci anni abbiamo
un agenzia di marketing che si occupa di
una branca molto specifica che si chiama
lead generation
il lead in realtà molto più semplice a
dirsi che che la parola ed è il contatto
di una persona interessata un
particolare argomento un prodotto un
servizio quindi per esempio quando noi
andiamo inserire la nostra e mail i
nostri dati sul sito per accedere da
qualche parte per avere un preventivo
quello che stiamo consegnando
è un leader perché un pacchetto di dati
personali nome me il telefono quello che
si sa e le aziende oggi sono disposta a
pagare anche molto molto molto molti
molti soldi per avere questi dati in
faccio degli esempi i dati di una
persona che vuole cambiare assicurazione
possono valere dai 60 ai 150 euro anche
di più america per esempio per i dati di
una persona che vuole provare una nuova
palestra o un nuovo piano telefonico
possono valere dai 10 ai 30 euro ma come
funziona oggi le aziende per ottenere
questi dati oggi compro la pubblicità da
quelli che io chiamo i mercanti
dell'attenzione facebook google per
cercare di ottenerli mostrare delle
pubblicità alle persone giuste per
convincere loro a dargli i dati allora
ci siamo chiesti dato che abbiamo fatto
questo per tanti anni abbiamo dato
tantissimi soldi facebook google ea
tutte le fonti di traffico ma non tipo
ma se se se invece di dare i soldi a
facebook google si pagasse l'utente che
vuole cambiare assicurazione l'utente
che vuole provare il nuovo servizio un
piano telefonico una palestra una
palestra professor ante quello che sia
tanto se è sempre la stessa persona
invece passare a facebook noi diamo
tagliamo l'intermediario che sta lì a
farci vedere le cose per trattenersi
sono piattaforma e crea creassimo un
collegamento diretto con questa persona
allora questa persona potrebbe
guadagnare direttamente questi 50 100 10
20 quello che sia per valutare un nuovo
servizio e questo è e così si potrebbe
guadagnare dei lati ma questo è solo un
esempio ad esempio della pubblicità il
primo che abbiamo scoperto perché era il
più vicino a noi in realtà è così su
tutti i dati si stima che i nostri dati
entro i prossimi anni potrebbero valere
dai 500 ai 1000 euro al mese a persone
quindi parliamo di qualcosa che può
cambiare
la realtà in cui viviamo ok tutto bello
ma come si fa come si fa
questa è una bella domanda perché per
riprenderci il valore dei nostri dati si
renderebbe la rivoluzione servirebbe un
progetto che possa entrare nelle
dinamiche di mercato e non qualcosa di
parastatale eccetera e che consideri
l'utente per la prima volta non come una
mucca da mungere
ma come un partner come un alleato
quindi una piattaforma
che possa mettere in contatto i dati con
chi gli vuole comprare e utilizzare in
maniera non una trasparente facendo poi
guadagnare l'utente per i propri dati
come se fosse un
bear che mette in contatto gli autisti
con i passeggeri come un derby che mette
in contatto i proprietari di casa con
gli ospiti che vogliono soggiornare in
quella casa così forse si potrebbe
creare un primo reddito generato dei
nostri dati ma c'è un piccolo problema
un piccolo grande problema che stiamo
parlando di un mercato controllato dalle
aziende più grandi al mondo non è un
modo di dire sono proprio le aziende più
grandi al mondo che non credo farebbero
propri salti di gioia a vedere questo
scenario avverato è veramente una guerra
di davide contro golia come si può
vincere una guerra di questo tipo
allora forse un modo ci sarebbe forse un
modo ci sarebbe perché i piccoli sono
più deboli finché non si organizzano un
po di persone che si organizza può fare
la rivoluzione togliere il potere da
pochi per ridarlo al popolo ma oggi
welcome nel 2021 non serve più la
violenza questa signora non so se la
riconoscete si chiama rosa park che un
giorno nel 1955 tornando a casa dal suo
turno di lavoro in autobus invece di
andarsi a sedere in un posto per neri
perché attenzione al tempo si in america
c'era la segregazione razziale
lei ha deciso di rimanere seduta sul suo
posto che era per bianchi e non cedere
il posto a un bianco per questa
insurrezione incredibile la presa di
posizione lei è stata arrestata foto qui
rosa park arrestata ma cosa è successo è
successo che la comunità nera di
montgomery si è organizzata è iniziato a
organizzarsi ea boicottare gli autobus
con una protesta che è durata più di un
anno e cosa è successo che dozzine e
dozzine di pullman sono rimaste fi sono
rimasti fermi inutilizzati per mesi
finchè alla fine non si sono arresi e
hanno rimosso la legge che legalizzava
la segregazione ancora una volta tanti
piccoli che si organizzano hanno vinto
contro chi era al potere ma oggi con la
tecnologia ci possiamo organizzare
meglio che nel 1955 possiamo anche fare
di più che boicottare siamo riusciti a
creare delle monete non controllate da
nessun governo o banca centrale nel suo
tipo dire no non puoi usarle si chiamano
cripto valute oggi le conosciamo tutti
oppure non so se avete sentito il caso
di gamestop o dei meme stock sono le
azioni che si trasmettono tramite mail
ed internet che hanno dimostrato per la
prima volta nella storia di come milioni
di piccoli investitori che si
organizzano possono vincere contro i
giganti e far perdere a questi giganti
gli investitori professionisti di wall
street miliardi di dollari
e cosa vuol dire questo che oggi
organizzati non siamo un davide contro
golia tante persone che si organizzano
sono più forti di poche che sono al
potere tante persone organizzate possono
e hanno già cambiato la storia e possono
quindi anche riprendersi il valore dei
propri dati questa è la rivoluzione di
cui parlavo all'inizio questa la
rivoluzione che sogniamo è la
rivoluzione dei dati in cui per la prima
volta un gruppo di persone organizzate
da tutto il mondo cercherà di
riprendersi i diritti sui propri dati e
per creare il primo reddito generato dai
nostri dati che noi chiamiamo human data
income un reddito generato dai dati
dell'essere umano è un valore nostro di
nostra proprietà che abbiamo e che già
crea un valore economico nel mondo e
quindi quello che potrebbe creare questo
io mandata in cam e ridistribuire dei
soldi che già esistono e già circolano e
alzare così il livello della ricchezza
del mondo
grazie